good morning believe nation today's
message is practice practice practice
over to you al pacino you look for that
thing that that that moves you I don't
know what it is
I like repetition I there's a saying
goes rep repetition repetition keeps me
green yeah I love that same repetition
keeps me green keeps me green become
fresh because the idea that we do
performance is over and over again you
would say well doesn't that get boring
or stale but no it's in the repetition
that the creation comes that the
expression comes because I'll give you
an example I was doing Richard once not
particularly well and this show is going
on and we couldn't get this court scene
with a lot of people in it I didn't
understand what I was doing in the scene
so we would call rehearsals I would
rehearse it and we would talk about it
think about it you know like all this
kind of work with people together trying
to figure out something in the 85th
performance of Richard I had done my
85th entrance
I knew the court scene I understood it I
I was there I could play but not in 84
not maybe four I was I might have been
getting closer than realize it yeah I
gave up the ghost I guess I just gave it
up and said oh screw it it's not gonna
happen and I'll just keep going on and I
found it I love this message and I often
get asked is it about quantity or
quality and the answer is both the
answer is its quality but to get the
quality you got to put in the quantity
to get really good at something soon to
know how to create something of great
quality of something that people would
really enjoy using of high value you
need to put in the work the quantity
leads to the quality you don't just wake
up and produce massive value comes from
all the hard work of understanding how
your industry works if I look at my
youtube channel as an example
but I've done like 3,000 videos over
3,000 videos not all of them are public
but that's 3,000 videos that's a lot of
video it's like I would hope that I
would get better after doing 3,000
videos and a lot of you guys have three
videos up and you're disappointed in the
results that you're not where you want
to be and I still have a long way to go
like these people that I looked up to
like a Les Brown you know legends of the
industry great speakers that I feel I
still have a lot to learn from that I
feel I'm nowhere even close and for me
to get there I need to practice and
practice and practice and practice and
that applies to any business when you
are launching a company and you're
trying to provide value to your
customers that value will come from all
the experience that you have and if you
have no experience yet that's okay but
understand that you don't get we provide
a lot of value yet and so you need to
hone your skills better and practice and
practice and practice and practice and
put in the quantity so you learn how to
create something of quality so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
your take on quality versus quantity
what do you think what's more important
and why leave in the comments below and
I will join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to Mia
knezovich I hope I pronounced that okay
Mia thank you so much for buying a copy
of my book really means a lot to me
appreciate that support losing guys
watching you want your chance and eye
shadow in the future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book it's really
good I promise and then email in your
receipt so you can keep track and also
send you the bonuses thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot I've been so